David grush is the guy who testified
under oath that the US government is in
possession of non-human aircraft plus
non-human biologic meaning effectively
alien Pilots the craft that we have
obtained our government specifically the
DIA the defense intelligence agency it
was admitted that they had a UFO program
you heard about it in the New York Times
I had the head of the DIA UFO program
come on my podcast with George nap and
he admitted that they had a craft and
they breached the whole of it it wasn't
made by us wasn't China wasn't Russia so
they call it non-human intelligence
right because we're not exactly sure
where the pilots or The Operators of The
Craft are from but that is fact he got
authorized to say it through a doser
request which just means he asked the
government hey what can I talk about but
he admitted it on the show